Empieza al entrar por la puerta.
No saben nada de ustedes.
Y pueden darles emoción...
todas las presentaciones, las propuestas de ventas son algo emocionales.
Pueden subir, bajar, ¿verdad?
Y va de principio a fin.
Entran. La primera cosa que hay que hacer
--el arco general de su presentación--
es empezar como un cohete.
Tienen tal vez 10 segundos --entre 10 y 30 segundos,
según lo que dure la presentación-- para llamar su atención.
En mi caso: "He invertido. He obtenido decenas de millones de dólares
de presentaciones en PowerPoint.
He invertido millones de dólares".
Directo al punto.
Puede ser un factor, que todos digan que no es intuitivo
Una historia, una experiencia.
Tiene que captar su atención emocional, centrarla en ustedes,
en esos primeros pocos segundos.
Y desde ahí tienen que llevarlos por un sólido y firme camino ascendente.
Y todo debe reforzar eso.
Y ha de mejorar, mejorar, mejorar y mejorar.
Y debe llevar todo al mismísimo final
y al final, tiene que --¡bum!-- atraerlos,
marcarles un gol.
Quieren ser capaces de darles un subidón emocional tal
que estén listos para darles un cheque, dinero,
justo antes irse.
¿Cómo se hace eso?
Antes de nada, una progresión lógica.
Cada vez que retroceden, cada vez que dan un paso atrás,
imaginen que suben por una escalera a la que le faltan peldaños,
o con escalones de distintas alturas.
Hay que pararse a analizarlo.
Quieren una progresión lógica.
Empiecen con el mercado.
Por qué van a hacer X, Y o Z.
Y después tienen que decirles cómo van a hacerlo, y qué van a hacer
Cómo lo llevarán a cabo.
El conjunto tiene que fluir de principio a fin.
También tienen que hacerme saber que hay referentes.
Relacionarlo con el resto del mundo exterior.
Por ejemplo,
si se refieren a compañías de las que oído hablar,
o a elementos básicos de su negocio, quiero saber de ellos.
Cosas con las que establecer una relación:
una validación, algo que me diga que alguien más aprueba esto
o que hay aprobación externa.
Pueden ser ventas, puede ser que tengan un premio por algo,
puede ser que alguien lo haya hecho antes,
puede ser que las pruebas iniciales van muy bien.
Lo que sea. Quiero validación,
que me digan que no solo lo dicen ustedes,
sino que alguien más --o alguien ahí fuera--
dice que tiene sentido.
Como busco la parte buena,
necesito que esa sea creíble.
Y eso son dos partes.
Ha de ser bueno y ha de ser creíble.
Bueno quiere decir que si dicen que estarán
5 años ganando un millón al año...
mmm, eso no es bueno de verdad.
Que van a ganar mil millones al año...
eso no es creíble.
Debe cumplir ambas partes.
Muchas cosas llevan cuesta abajo,
bajan el nivel emocional,
y tienen que recuperarse de ellas.
Por ejemplo, decir cosas
que sepa que no son ciertas.
"No habrá competencia.
Nadie ha hecho un aparato como éste".
De pronto sé de alguien que lo ha hecho.
Y en ese momento: ¡bum!
Descuento la mitad de lo que me digan desde entonces.
Cualquier cosa que me haga pensar. Lo que no entienda,
lo que me pida deducir algo, en mi cabeza,
va a parar el fluir de la presentación.
Me tienen que llevar de la mano como a un niño
--bla, bla, bla-- pero sin ser condescendientes.
Y eso es muy difícil de hacer.
Pero si pueden hacerlo funciona muy, muy bien.
Cualquier cosa que no sea coherente con su concepto.
Si me dicen ventas de X, Y o Z 10 millones de dólares,
y en la siguiente diapositiva o después, 5 millones.
Podría ser ganancias brutas,
y ganancias netas,
pero quiero saber que todas las cifras tienen sentido.
Y en último lugar cualquier fallo, un error tipográfico
o una equivocación tonta o una línea que no está en su lugar
me muestra que si no pueden hacer una presentación,
¿cómo van a llevar una empresa?
Todo esto funciona en conjunto.
Lo mejor es mirar a los mejores,
a los que lo han hecho antes.
Así que echemos un ojo al ejecutivo de tecnología más exitoso del mercado
y veamos cómo va una presentación.
La presentación en PowerPoint de Bill Gates.
Gates en un acto sobre Windows.
¿Es así como se hace una presentación?
¿Qué creen?
No. ¿En quién creéis que deberíamos fijarnos como modelo?
¡Qué divertido! Es otro de los grandes.
¿Si? Steve Jobs.
Quieren el absoluto, es el Zen de las presentaciones, ¿no?
Ahí está. Un hombrecillo, tejanos negros y tal,
un escenario completamente vacío.
¿En qué nos centramos?
¡En él! Es Steve Jobs.
Ya ven, genial,
esos maravillosos "bullets", una gran lista de cosas... ¡bien!
No, no.
Los "bullets" largos son malos.
¿Qué es bueno? "Bullets" bien cortos.
Pero ¿saben qué?
Mejor que cortos es no usarlos.
Solo un encabezado.
¿Y saben qué?
¿Cuantos "bullets" o encabezados usa Steve Jobs?
Básicamente ninguno.
¿Qué hacer?
Lo mejor: imágenes. Una imagen simple.
Miro la imagen... vale más que mil palabras.
Miran la imagen, lo ven y lo captan todo.
Y entonces vuelven a mí.
Se centran en mí, en por qué soy tan buen tipo
por qué quieren invertir en mí.
En por qué todo esto tiene sentido.
Dicho esto, tenemos muy poco tiempo,
veamos las cosas que debe incluir
su presentación.
Lo primero de todo, el principio. Nada de diapositivas con largos títulos
con bla, bla, bla,
y presento esto y lo otro.
Sé que día es, quién soy, que presentan.
Eso no hace falta.
Usen el logotipo de la empresa.
Veré el logotipo y quedará en mi cerebro.
Y volveré a ustedes y me centraré en ustedes.
Hagan eso, empiecen con una rápida
introducción de 15-30 segundos, capten mi atención.
Y después tendrán que darme una visión general del negocio.
No una presentación de cinco minutos, sino dos frases.
"Hacemos aparatos para el mercado X, Y o Z".
O "Vendemos servicios para ayudar a la gente a hacer X". Lo que sea.
Es como la foto en la caja de un rompecabezas.
Me informa el contexto.
Me da el armazón de todo
lo que me van a explicar.
Y me permite relacionar todo lo demás con algo
que ya me han dicho.
Háganlo, guíenme,
muéstrenme su equipo gestor.
Ayuda que tengan experiencia,
Y quiero conocer el mercado, su tamaño.
¿Por qué vale la pena este mercado?
Quiero conocer el producto.
No me lo presenten, no es una venta.
No quiero todos los detalles
cómo funciona y esas cosas.
Solo quiero saber qué demonios es.
Si es una web, muestren una captura de la Web.
No hagan una demostración en vivo.
Nunca una demostración en vivo.
Hagan una demo algo que diga
por qué comprarán lo que sea que es.
Entonces querré saber --ahora que ya sé qué venden--
cómo obtener dinero con ello.
Por cada X vendido obtienen Y, hacen servicio Z.
Quiero saber el modelo empresarial
por unidad o por producto real
que venden.
Quiero saber a quién venden,
en clientes.
Quiero saber si tienen contactos
que les ayudarán.
Si tienen una relación de distribución,
si tienen un socio productor.
O, ya saben, de nuevo, validación.
Eso ayuda a decir que son parte de algo más grande.
Pero todo el mundo tiene competencia.
Nunca ha existido la empresa
sin competencia.
Aún si es la manera antigua de hacer algo.
Quiero saber exactamente quién es su competencia
para poder juzgar
cómo encaja en todo el contexto.
Saber qué los hace especiales.
Sé lo que hace su competencia,
¿cómo impedirán que
se coman su pastel?
Eso enlaza con la visión general de las cuentas.
Imprescindible.
No pueden ir con ICR sin mostrar las cuentas.
Quiero información de uno o dos años atrás.
O desde que existan.
Y quiero una proyección de cuatro o cinco años.
Cinco quizá mucho; cuatro es razonable.
Quiero saber cómo el modelo de negocio que enseñaron
con base en un producto, se traduce en un modelo.
Cuántos aparatos van a vender.
Ganan X dinero por aparato.
Quiero saber los márgenes.
Tendremos 1000 clientes este año
y 10 000 el año que viene.
Nuestras ganancias subirán a tanto.
Eso me da una imagen de los siguientes años
en que invertiré.
Saber cómo el dinero que obtendrán de mí
los ayudará a llegar allí.
Si van a abrir una planta en China,
si se van a gastar todo en promoción y ventas,
si van a ir a Tahití, o lo que sea.
Pero luego viene la pregunta.
Aquí me dicen cuánto quieren conseguir.
Buscan 5 millones, ¿con qué valoración de capital?
2 millones a 100 000.
¿Cuánto dinero han conseguido ya? ¿De quién?
Espero que inviertan personalmente.
Porque yo voy detrás.
Si no invierten en su proyecto, ¿por qué hacerlo yo?
Quiero saber si tienen familia y amigos,
inversores ángel u otros ICRs antes.
¿Cuál es la estructura de capital hoy?
Y, último, después de todo,
ya que me lo han explicado todo,
tienen que volver a la conclusión.
Es el cohete que sube.
Con suerte todo habrá sido positivo, positivo, positivo
y más positivo.
Y todo lo que me dicen encaja,
todo tiene sentido.
Y pienso: "Esto es realmente genial".
Vuelven a mostrar el logotipo.
Solo el logotipo en pantalla.
Y miro al logotipo. Vale, bien.
Vuelvo a mirarlos. Nada más que ver, ¿no?
Entonces tienen que atar todos los cabos.
Tienen que darme el final, ya saben, ¡bum!
La propuesta que me pondrá en órbita.
Durante todo el proceso,
¿cómo recordarán la secuencia y lo que hacer?
Habrán notado que no miro a la pantalla.
La pantalla, en esta sala, está delante de mí.
No podría verla ni aunque quisiera.
Y ¿cómo veo lo que sucede en ella?
Tengo un portátil delante, pero me están mirando,
y ven esto.
¿Qué creen que veo yo?
¿Creen que es lo mismo?
No, de hecho veo una versión especial
de PowerPoint aquí
que me muestra las diapositivas anteriores, las que siguen,
mis notas... así que veo cómo va todo.
Esto está en todas las copias de PowerPoint
que venden.
Si usan Keynote, de Apple, tiene una versión incluso mejor.
Y hay un programa que se llama Ovation
de Adobe desde el verano pasado,
que te ayuda a manejar todos los tiempos,
y permite orientarse en el conjunto.
Aquí está el final que los pondrá en órbita, ¿bueno?
David da listas de 10, no hay tiempo para 10.
Los 5 consejos de David son:
Uno: Usen siempre la vista de presentador,
Ovation o Presenter Tools
porque permite ver hacia dónde se dirigen,
a controlar el ritmo, tiene un cronómetro
para poder acabar a tiempo.
Cuatro: Usen siempre un mando a distancia.
¿Me han visto tocar el computador?
No, porque estoy usando este mando a distancia.
Úsenlo siempre.
Tres:
No entreguen la presentación.
Si siguen mis consejos, tendrán una presentación parca, muy zen.
Que es genial para transmitir
quienes son y para involucrar a la gente.
Pero no como material de apoyo.
Quieren dar un documento con mucha más información,
porque debe servir sin ustedes.
Tres:
No lean su charla.
¿Se imaginan? "Inviertan en mi empresa
porque es muy buena".
No funciona, ¿verdad? No lo lean.
Y el consejo número uno para presentar:
Nunca, jamás, miren a la pantalla.
Están conectando con el público ante ustedes,
y quieren siempre conectar cara a cara.
La pantalla debe estar atrás de ustedes,
y apoyar lo que dicen, no sustituirlos.
Así es como se presenta ante un ICR.